let's go to lindsay in woodbridge
virginia
lindsey how are you doing i'm good thank
you for taking my call today
you bet thanks for giving us a shout
what's going on so i have a question
about baby step
two and whether or not i need to put
money aside for a possible divorce
so i've been married for eight years i
have several young children
i am the um working mom and then my
husband is a stay-at-home dad
great dad really good dad um and we are
really great roommates
we're best friends we do everything
together but from the day we got married
i knew there was something wrong
i initially thought there was something
wrong with me because we had
no intimacy no you know
cuddling just like there was something
wrong i found out during my last
pregnant just a couple years ago that
he crossed dresses and he has been in a
relationship with at least one other man
prior to getting married to me nothing
after getting married to me that i know
of
um i can't
be attracted to someone who is actively
cross-dressing and he
is not interested in anything without it
okay and so
while we are really good roommates i am
very very lonely
very lonely and some days i just don't
think i can do it
but other than that we are a really you
know we're good friends our kids are
happy
i don't think our kids have any clue
that we have any relationship problems
and so with us being in the middle of
baby step two we've paid off about
two hundred thousand we have just under
two hundred thousand to go
uh are you a doctor yes i am okay there
you go
i was gonna say man that's a lot of
student loans right great guess
yes but we're almost done yeah um
i i don't know should i stop it and put
money aside for a possible divorce or if
i am
content enough should i just keep
going and keep working on the baby steps
and just ignore that aspect
we have tried counseling he's not
interested in any changes he's not
interested in following up and
counseling so where does that put you
when you say possible divorce he's not
interested in any counseling
you've already expressed your emotion
and where you're at so what's
where are you at when you say possible
divorce
while i'm content most of the time i am
so lonely sometimes
i don't know how long i can stay married
to someone lindsay what kind of
testimony
what kind of doctor are you i'm primary
care
okay so i can i'm going to speak to you
like a fellow geek for a second is that
okay
um you know the the jama
the journal of american medical
association you know the diseases of
despair
data don't you yes we are amidst
a loneliness epidemic that is killing us
through all sorts of chaotic
inflammatory responses
right whether it is addiction
or whether it is people taking their own
lives or whether it is
what the articles are calling long tail
suicide
through organ disease failure right
and so i'm just speaking geek to you for
a second
as a way to to soften the blow here
but you can't live a life of loneliness
just because he's a great father
just because y'all are great roommates
doesn't mean
that you've got to stay married and
you've got to stay lonely
right part of um
part of a marriage is two people working
together
to co-create a future and i don't care
what the other like the the the fact
that he has
been with other people the fact that he
has a way of
um showing his authenticity to himself
to his core group of people
and you have said i don't want to be a
part of that moving forward and he has
said well tough luck
then i don't want to be the one to tell
you this lindsay but you called the show
he has
said my authenticity in this moment is
more important than being
married to you yeah that's a really nice
way saying that i'm going to jump in and
say he's made it very clear he doesn't
want to be married to you he doesn't
want to fix it this is a whole different
deal
or he wants to be married on his terms
right i
can't i just don't that's not being
married
so there is a relationship contract it's
not a legal document
me i think married is we're together
that's right that's right no
it's not just in the same house this guy
may be a fantastic fantastic roommate
but you're going to crash you're going
to crash
hard you have crashed haven't you you
might have uh
i was admitted for depression a couple
of years ago but i've gotten to the
point where i recognize it wasn't
my failing in the marriage i gave it
everything i had sure yeah so
so what's left what are you waiting on
it's hard to do it looking at my kids
yep it is
yeah that's that's that's true uh let's
talk about the financial piece john here
because you've got 200 000 left so yeah
we want you to pause
because you're in the midst of a really
big storm and so you need to pause
paying off the the debt snowball until
we until we figure out
the when the how yeah what's that gonna
look like i mean it's just too uncertain
so
we want to pause right that's the
financial piece the financial
piece is um yes you got to pause the
baby steps
and because you have a
as in to use your words because y'all
are still best friends
because you've got a good relationship
you can sit down and have this
it's going to be a very hard very
challenging but a factual conversation
here's where we are at
and i'm not willing to
continue to be lonely inside my own home
anymore
and you've made it clear that you're not
interested in co-creating a future
together with me
and so as ken said as i said
he your husband's painting the picture
for you right and now
not by your hand but in your lap now
you're forced to make some hard
decisions
and here's where we are and i don't know
that you're going to find two people
more high on marriage than ken and i um
i'm not in the business of telling
people in their marriage
but i am in the business of telling the
truth and the reality is lindsay you've
told me your marriage is over
and that it is at this point it's
drowning you yeah and i'm not gonna sit
by and watch
a friend be drown right so yeah
as far as the money goes hard
conversation you got to pause the baby
steps you're all going to have to
make some hard decisions about how
you're going to move forward together
how are you going to work out the
parenting all that stuff's going to have
to happen together
this is not going to be an easy road
moving forward i hope everybody can act
like an adult and you all can work
together in this transition
and i always always always i'm gonna
circle back to my hope for
um reconciliation for people to come
together um but you've been doing that
for a long time
and so it's time to call what it is what
it is and make the hard hard decisions
together
and then continue to honor each other
around your kids
don't ever ever ever be in the
badmouthing game
either of you honor each other in front
of your kids and this is going to be a
hard hard season to walk
um and i want to thank you for honoring
us with your trust here i know this is a
hard call to make
and um we'll be thinking about you
moving forward yeah and i just say this
that you know
you've done some great things in in
paying off 200 000
worth of debt you're going through some
extremely extremely painful stuff
personally
pressing pause don't feel guilty for
that for a second you work through all
this that john said and then there's
going to be a season where you'll be
able to pick back up and you'll get
there
and hopefully it's whole uh in a in a
healthy relationship where you're not
alone so
and i want to call second guess it let's
let's um in ken
i think it's important to not let
people off the hook here it's easy to
hear a call like this and go
i don't know anybody who dresses in
women's clothes or who feels this way or
is attracted to
people i get this call all the time ken
about video games and about alcohol
and about spending money and about have
to have another car and a house this
size
where you get somebody who's married and
the
person they're married to says i'm doing
my life this way
without you that's right that's exactly
right that's right
the really the details and the
sensational whatever you think is
sensational whether you don't think it's
sensational
the fact of the matter is is when one of
the spouses says i'm not interested in
counseling which means i'm not
interested in reconciliation i'm not
interested
and they've been unfaithful
then you know it's not by your hand but
in your lap and you've got some hearts
you've been forced to deal with it and
so you don't quit living you keep moving
i hate that for i really do and the kids
stay in there lindsay stay in there